[موسيقى]
إن الطيران يكلفك الكثير من الطاقة إذا
كنت نحلة وتحتاج إلى
محطات توقف منتظمة تحتاج إلى محطات توقف منتظمة للوقود
[موسيقى]
الزحف العمراني
المكثف قد ترك الريف
والمناظر الطبيعية لدينا
بيئة صعبة للتنقل ،
لذا إذا كانوا
تعثر على منطقة مزروعة بشكل مكثف لم تعمل في أي
توفير لموائل أو
نباتات مزهرة
يمكن أن ينتهي بها الأمر بالتعب وتقطيع
الكتل الحيوية للحشرات
وستسمع غالبًا أشخاص يتحدثون عنها
جيدًا في يومي عندما كنت أستخدم
لقيادة السيارة ، سأقوم بمسح الحشرات
من على شاشتي ، وقد توقف ذلك
[موسيقى]
، لقد أنشأوا خريطة تمثل أساسًا
مخططًا يضم جميع
الموائل الغنية بالزهور البرية المتبقية ويظهر
المسار الأقل مقاومة في
بينها ويوضح لنا المكان الذي نحتاج فيه إلى وضع
الزهور البرية في الريف
لإحداث تأثير حجر الانطلاق
حتى في وعاء نباتات صغير أو سرير مرتفع
في حديقتك المحلية أو على حافة النافذة الخاصة
بك  أي شيء إذا كانت هناك
رقعة خضراء ، قطعة من الزهور
تساعد على المساهمة في
الخط المباشر ،
ما هو جميل في الاعتناء
بالحشرات ومشاهدتها لأنها تستجيب بسرعة
للعمل الذي تزرعه بجوار الزهور
الغنية وتقضي بعض الوقت في مشاهدتها
، فسترى النحل  عند دخولك إلى حديقتك
، سترى حوامات سترى
عثًا وفراشات وهذا له
تأثير
في المملكة المتحدة والعالم حول
هذا كوكب يستحق الحماية ،
أخبرنا كيف تجيب على المكالمة باستخدام
علامة التجزئة الرائعة على الأرض